hello and
thank you everybody for joining us today
my name is sven buckland and i'm senior
director of scientific affairs and
marketing here at bionic genomics and i
would like to welcome you to this
webinar brought to you by lap roots and
sponsored by
bioneergenomics the webinar is called
isolating ultra high molecular weight
dna for genome-wide structural variant
analysis
and it will be presented by dr ben
clifford and by me
sven bachmann bionano has been working
on the isolation of mega-base-sized dna
molecules for over a decade
for our optical mapping or genome
imaging technology
we were hoping to share some of that
experience with you today
first up is dr ben clifford who is our
senior field application scientist
he will talk about all the tips and
tricks for sample handling and dna
isolation
then i will take a few minutes to show
you the things that you can do
with that ultra high molecular weight
dna that you just can't do with shorter
molecules
and finally we will answer as many
questions as we can
we encourage you to submit as many
questions as you want at any time you
want
during the presentation to do so just
type them into the ask a question box
and click
on the send button if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
with that dr clifford the virtual floor
is yours
thank you dr bachman hi everybody thank
you so much for joining
uh my name is ben clifford i'm senior
field application scientist at bionano
genomics
and for anybody who is not familiar with
bionano our platform is
pictured here on the title slide we have
the sapphire system
and as sven said it is uh it does whole
genome imaging
uh so it's not a sequencing based
approach it's genome imaging
and the reason that that's important is
that genomes are highly repetitive
and so if you look at just a breakout of
the contents here the human genome
only around one third of it consists of
unique sequences
the other two thirds are repetitive
elements so lines signs transposon
anything else bound in repeats uh and so
shorter technologies like
sequencing can often get confounded by
these repetitive elements
and lose context for what an individual
read
might be covering and when we talk about
structural variation
we're talking about the largest uh
events in the genome chromosomal
rearrangements or large uh oftentimes
events
so here insertions deletions uh out to
inversions and even translocations at
the chromosomal level
and because of the challenges with ngs
for example the clinical standard of
care for some of these largest events
has been the karyotype but that's uh
slow and not particularly scalable
um and so really where we sit is
bringing some of the same advantages
that sequencing data applies the
scalability
and the event detection precision
and that's where bionano's data type is
particularly valuable so here's an
image from the sapphire system this is
showing
high molecular weight long intact dna
molecules
in our nano channel arrays that have
been labeled and stained with our label
in chemistry
these fill in uh for reeds but they are
much much
longer and this approach really requires
the
long molecules in fact we only carry
forward
molecules longer than 150 000
base pairs in equivalent 150 kp
and this is really what allows bionano
to assemble entire chromosome
arms span these long repetitive complex
regions that are often confounded by
shorter approaches
in fact in the image here on the right
of the slide is some more of our data
and you can even see
visually pick out some repeat
motifs so there's a few strings of
labels that are consecutively
shown and we can span most of those
regions
as well as flanking regions to identify
where those repeats exist in the genome
this approach really requires bio nano
prep
dna isolation to attain the long ultra
clean dna
i'm sorry to say if you have a freezer
full of dna that's been archived that's
been isolated from
other methods then frozen it's just
going to be too short
short molecules and impure samples just
aren't likely to be informative
once they're labeled and imaged in this
way either they're too for
too short and that native information
from the length is lost
or the prep is too dirty and it won't
label efficiently
like we needed to and be informative for
the downstream assembly process
and so the rest of my section is really
going to be
addressing sample selection
selected your samples and gently
handling the sample
at the sample and dna level those
factors are critically important when it
comes
to prepping this dna and
uh what you get in following these best
practices here's a histogram
of molecule lengths coming off of the
sapphire instrument
so this is a particularly good run this
was
has a molecule m50 so a center of mass
of this size distribution uh 434 kb
434 000 base pairs
if you look to the left this red circled
area this is typically what you get with
long read sequencing approaches
20 30 kb sometimes a little higher
than 50 lengths our center of mass is
typically much much higher than that
really anywhere uh 250 kb
and up is is typical um
we we will uh uh often speak in terms of
n50
for where the center of massive
distribution is uh
although some molecules in the
distribution go up past
a megabase even past 2 megabase 2
million base pairs in length
but what's really informative for our
downstream assembly process
is where the center of your data set
resides in terms of length
and then just to take a sample that's
processed through the bio nano prep
if we look at that on a pulse field gel
uh that really gets at the size
even before it hits the labeling
chemistry or the instrument
so here's a pulse field gel these bottom
two uh rows
are native dna that have been isolated
via bioneno prep methods and the
important thing to look at this
uh rather long ladder goes to 825 kb
if you look at the banding pattern on
the bottom two rows
before that there's dna present in what
we call the megabase compression zone
so these isolations contain megabase dna
the top two rows here are the dle1
labeled dna samples that are going on
the chip they also have
megabase dna at the compression zone
that's megabases that you're loading
into the chip
that can then potentially be imaged on
the sapphire
and so detecting structural variation
really starts with these long dna
molecules
and we we have a number of protocols
now using solution phase prep
our previous um uh methodology for this
was based in plug lysis
uh which i just want to address briefly
this is using an agarose gel plug
to provide megabase size dna uh and
physically shield the sample so what
that starts out as is cellular material
um with its native state dna in it
and then you're providing an agarose gel
matrix of protection
around it and from there uh there are a
series of lysis steps
where the cellular material anything
that's not dna can be lysed and digested
away with protein sk
and lysis buffer and there after a
series of wash steps the agarose
itself can be melted away and then
you're just left with high molecular
weight dna
solubilized this is not very scalable
however
or very fast that's a number of
hours and an overnight incubation and we
wanted to be a bit faster than that but
the problem with most
fast dna protocols whether you're using
a spin column
or magnetic beads or precipitating to
the bottom of the tube
is it's just too much mechanical force
on
this native fragile dna
and it gets you short reads so we
developed a bio nano prep
sp solution phase dna isolation protocol
that's both
fast and mechanically protective of the
dna
and just to outline how it works we take
a
biological material from one tube and
then undergo a lysis process
and gently release dna into solution
it's then bound on a magnetic disk
where it can be washed on the disk and
then transferred to a new clean tube
once it is clean and then eluded in an
aleutian buffer
and just to give you a real example of
what this looks like here are a couple
of tubes
with two black magnetic discs in them
and then each one looks like it's bound
up in cobwebs a bit
so this is what the dna looks like
precipitated out of the solution and
then
bound magnetically to the disk
you have these white wisps that just
attach to the disk
uh it can all be washed as one unit and
then transferred to a new clean tube
and so this process really it's
critically important to handle
the sample carefully store and treat the
sample carefully
we do tend to see our very longest
molecules
with samples that are fresh and have
never been frozen
but there are freeze options as well
for the following sample types whole
blood bone marrow aspirate
cultured cells and then new to the
lineup
tissue so we have a solution phased
approach in
human and animal tissues tumors
using sp and then we do have workflows
for plants as well
those are currently supported with
agarose plug
based workflows i'll go through each of
these
in turn so for
whole human blood samples we recommend
these be drawn into eda2
and then there is an option to process
that blood
same day fresh without freezing
and with that entails if you are going
to store it for any length of time that
it be stored at four degrees celsius
and then prepped within 4 days of that
initial draw
if that's not possible or if you'd
rather store
blood and get to it later there is a
freeze option
with this workflow that would be to mix
the original
stabilization tube and then make small
aliquots
650 microliters is really all it takes
and then place those at -80 and
have those available when you're ready
to work with it
this workflow supported by shown below
the by nano sp
prep blood and cell culture isolation
kit
uh there's a similar workflow available
for bone marrow aspirate
now bone marrow aspirate's a bit
challenging it can be a complex sample
type
just due to the nature of sample
collection so we've added a filtration
step
so occasionally there is bone shard
sometimes skin or fat left over in the
sample
so we want to remove all of the crude
bulk material
and just leave the white blood cells
another
possible complication with bone marrow
aspirate is these are collected
typically in heparin tubes
heparin for our purposes as a stabilizer
just does not is not very effective in
stabilizing
the cells through a freeze-thaw cycle so
what we recommend is to add in
a reagent dna stabilizer
15 microliters per 1 ml of crude bone
marrow aspirate
titrate accordingly if your volume is
slightly different
we see our best results and strongly
recommend adding this
while the bone marrow aspirate is still
fresh before it's frozen
and it can be mixed together well if
bone marrow aspirate has been frozen
beforehand
uh quickly upon thawing you can dose in
a an aliquot of dna stabilizer
that will add some benefit but typically
the easiest way to work with this
material
is to mix it up in dna stabilizer and
make one ml aligots
which then can be placed at minus 80.
this
workflow is supported by the bio
nanoprep sp bone marrow aspirate dna
isolation kit
which includes those filters and the
extra dna stabilizer
cultured cells are also quite readily
handled
if you're electing to work with these
fresh
cells in culture the culture should be
high viability
ideally it's actively growing
in which case you would simply count out
1.5 million human cells
and begin the protocol so you'd carry
the volume equivalent of 1.5 million
forward after doing a cell count this
1.5 million figure
this is to target 9 micrograms of dna
equivalent
going into the reaction more on that in
just a second
there's also a freeze option with
cultured cells
if you have cells in culture and you'd
rather freeze them down into pellets
that's certainly possible
you'd simply count out your desired
input
and then wash again in this dna
stabilizer
to promote viability in those cells upon
freezing them
and thawing them back out you'd pellet
the material once it's been washed in
stabilizer
and then place those tubes at minus 80.
and this workflow is supported by the
same kit as the whole blood
the bio nanoprep sp blood and cell
culture
isolation kit
now each of these uh three workflows
that i've described blood bone marrow
and cell
have a number of commonalities that i
want to address just to get
into the mechanism a bit more
specifically
in each one the cells at some point are
counted to 1.5 million
uh human cells as the tarpon foot this
translates to
an input of nine micrograms of dna
equivalent
of the material we like nine micrograms
as a target as that
that provides enough material to have a
good dna
yield a target concentration of the
solubilized sample once you have it
as output but it's not an excessive
amount of material
it's less than 650 microliters whole
blood
for example and really minimizing
unnecessary input
is helpful for the efficiency in the
wash steps
so you're minimizing how much
there is to wash out in every case cell
viability
is really key if the cells are
inviable in a significant degree if
nucleases are already attacking that dna
you're going to see shorter molecules
once you get to the labeling
and and running the sapphire
and so for electing the freeze options
here that's where stabilizing the sample
properly really comes in
and then once uh any frozen sample is
frozen at minus 80
samples really must not go undergo any
freestyle
cycling so those are freeze thaw cycles
just represent
iterations of a damage to the dna
now i mentioned at the outset we have
early access
kits and workflows available for human
and animal tissue just to go into that
briefly
we're seeing good results with
10 milligram and up of flash frozen
tissue or tumor uh unfortunately
uh ffpe samples are uh not adequately
preserved and that won't work
on our platform um but once the
desired mass of tissue is harvested uh
it's simply a matter of rinsing it and
quickly snap freezing in liquid nitrogen
upon harvest you don't need a storage
medium
we don't recommend using any kind of
storage medium outside of just snap
freeze and liquid nitrogen
let that gas off cap the tube handle it
on dry ice
until the sample can be transferred to
minus 80.
this workflow is again in early access
it's
supported by the bioneno sp prep tumor
and tissue
dna isolation kit um if you are
interested
uh in in this workflow or in any of our
workflows please contact us
and then we have a number of workflows
available for
plant tissue as well so each of these
start with harvesting
anywhere between 0.5 and maybe 2
grams of fresh growth from young plant
leaf tissue as
input with plants each
each one can be very different but one
commonality is you really want to
target young fresh plant leaf tissue
mature plants leaves that have grown a
lot of structural
compounds or metabolites secondary
metabolites in the tissue
are likely to lead to dirtier preps
lower dna yields
um the the fresher you can get the
better with these
we have a number of workflow options to
support different
uh plant compositions and metabolite
content
our workhorse protocol is a protocol
that works well for most
straightforward plant tissues there are
separate workflows
specific to secondary metabolite content
a high polyphenol
workflow as well as high polysaccharide
if those are issues to be concerned
about with your particular plant sample
as with the other workflows fresh works
great
in which case you just harvest the
tissue and then start straight away
homogenizing fresh plant tissue if
you're not ready to get to that same day
there's freeze options here as well
you'd harvest the tissue pre-weigh it
out and then
snap freeze in liquid nitrogen again no
storage media
really necessary to do this just snap
trees and liquid nitrogen let that gas
off and then transfer
a sample to minus 80 until you're ready
for it
if if the sample is frozen at this point
there's also a workflow option to
homogenize the sample entirely in liquid
nitrogen
this is just pulverizing it down into a
powder and then
using a wade powder to carry forward
into the dna isolation reaction
these workflows are all supported by the
bionano prep plant dna
isolation kit again this is a agarose
based method plug lysis
and there's a protocol selection guide
if you're not sure where your plant
falls
that will help you differentiate between
whether
it's better to use base high polyphenol
or the high polysaccharide option
so the output from any of these
processes
is solubilized ultra high molecular
weight dna
and then working with this and
preserving that native length that
you've worked
so hard to attain entails a few extra
care steps as well so if you look at the
picture on the right this is what a high
molecular weight dna sample looks like
the first thing you'll notice is the
texture is very different uh the sample
is viscous so it's it's a bit even
just like pipetting hair gel uh there
should be some texture and viscosity to
it
um any of the sp workflows
of the isolation protocol on a slow end
over end
dna rotation to gently promote some
mechanical mixing
and then that samples incubated
overnight at least overnight
at room temperature
returning to it the next day or uh or a
couple days down the line
it's critical to pipette slowly and very
carefully
and really to work with the viscosity so
realize it's not going to be
a uniform sub sample when you pipette it
just need to
uh need to work with it you never want
to vortex the sample
that will shear your dna systematically
and then it's strongly
recommended to keep wide orifice tips on
hand
so in this picture technicians using a
wide bore
p200 tip the orifice in the tip is wider
and that's to minimize any shearing of
just the sample
migrating in and out of the pipette tip
that's what we recommend for mixing
prior to any subsampling for dna
quantitation or labeling
this dna and then the gdna that you do
recover from this process
should be kept fresh you should never
freeze it the ice crystals will
shear the dna storage at room
temperature is just fine
if you're going longer term uh storing
the sample at 4c
also works
one other thing to keep in mind with
these viscous dna samples
is that the dna within them is often
heterogeneously distributed
so the viscosity in the sample really is
molecular interaction
of high molecular weight dna long
strands
interfering with one another and
providing a viscous
texture to that sample and that implies
and as often the case that the sample is
really quite heterogeneously distributed
when it comes time to quantitate that
dna uh what we do
is three sample aliquots per tube
small aliquots two microliters uh to
quantitate using fluorimetry
and we do need a fluorometric approach
um
to get this quantitation accurately and
then from those three assessing the mean
and the coefficient of variation and
just to illustrate some of the
challenges
in in doing this here's an example
of three different aliquots of
dna from the same tube so spatially
different positions
you can take from the left center and
right of the sample
just to ensure you're not hitting the
same spot three straight times
uh three different readings from the
same tube might look like
65 100 and 120
nanograms per microliter that's real
variation within that sample
if those were your three readings what
you do is take the mean
concentration of those three here it's
95 nanograms per microliter
and then of those three assess the
coefficient of variation so the standard
deviation
divided by the mean we
require a coefficient of variation
30 percent or below to have confidence
in the initial three aliquots that went
into this reading
so they need to agree with them 30 or so
of one another
before having confidence in the mean uh
if
uh the dna is incubated overnight and
then three aliquots are sub-sampled and
they
are wider than 30 percent and
coefficient of variation
that's not a static metric by any means
the the cure for that is simply just to
let the dna incubate longer at room
temperature
what happens then is it gives the dna
time to diffuse apart
and homogenize the sample some gentle
mixing there with the wide bore tip
is also an option but just to underscore
where these processes leave you
you end up with a very high ultra pure
molecular weight
dna isolation the initial input target
was 9 micrograms
dna equivalent and that's typically
output in about 120 microliters of
volume
which represents solubilized ultra high
quality
dna that you can carry forward for
labeling the
typical concentration the target that we
we aim for with that nine microgram
input
is 35 to 150 nanograms per microliter in
mean concentration
uh once you're at that point if you're
uh doing the bionano workflow
um it only requires 750 nanograms of dna
carried forward to be used in the direct
label and stain reaction
for running in the chip so we're
producing
quite an excess of dna that is actually
run in the instrument
and with that i'd like to hand things
back to sven to talk
a bit about the platform and structural
variation in genetic disease and cancer
same yes thank you ben
um i would like to um
start by summarizing a few things that
ben said and that it's really that
one of the reasons why we are all here
and
and are interested in these very long
dna molecules is that
the genomes of any complex organism are
just really highly repetitive
in human genomes generally about a third
consist of unique sequences and two
thirds consist of repeats and what's
important here is that if you have a
short read length
because you have short molecules but
also because you're using a method like
ngs
to look at the genome you just cannot
make sense of two thirds of the genome
because
almost all of the classes but all of
these single units of these different
repeat element classes
are already longer than the length of
short read sequencing
so making sense of that is impossible
and even with long-range sequencing
you're still not able to make it through
some of these long repeat arrays
here and that's why the standard of care
in the clinic
is not long read sequencing it's not a
high coverage aluminum but to look at
structural variants people look with a
microscope at
impact dna molecules and when ngs came
along there was this idea that all of
this could be replaced
with short read sequencing but the truth
is that an ngs protocol starts by
fragmenting the dna
you take a perfectly intact genome and
you shred it and that makes no sense
it's the same
idea of trying to tell you how many
pieces of kiwi were in this blender
after i turn it on and make a smoothie
it just doesn't make sense so we want
long impact dna and that is what this
seminar of course is all about
that's why the standard of care in the
clinic is still looking at impact dna
molecules and looking at
patterns on these molecules and that's
exactly what bioneno does
we place about a thousand times more
labels on these molecules then you can
see
with a karyotype and we massively
parallel
image and linearize these dna modules in
our nano channels array
our microscope is called sapphire and it
automates the labeling
sorry the imaging of these molecules
now this is how it all works this is the
workflow for
optical mapping with bioneno ben talked
extensively about the isolation part of
high molecular weight dna
next up then is labeling a specific
sequence motif
across the entire genome we do this with
a single enzymatic reaction that places
a label at a single six base pair
sequence motif
occurring all throughout the genome
about 500
000 times so once every 6 kb on average
once that label dna is loaded onto our
chips we will use electrophoresis to
move the molecules into the nano
channels
and image them and do this over and over
and over again
the images that are collected will then
be digitized
and the digital representation of each
of the molecules will be extracted and
then our software will perform a
complete lenovo assembly of the entire
genome meaning that every single
molecule that we image will be aligned
with every single
molecule that we imaged and so out of
these patterns that we find in these
overlapping molecules we build consensus
genome maps
that represent the structure of the
genome and then we can
call every type of structural variant
simply by comparing these patterns
in each of the examples here the
reference genome of your choice is in
green
and your sample is in blue and you see
on the left
that a gain or a loss so a deletion or
an insertion is detected by the spacing
between the labels
decreasing for a deletion or increasing
for an insertion
with by nano we can call those starting
at 500 base pairs
we can look at repeat arrays i will show
you some examples of that in a second
either by counting the repeats or by
measuring the distance between the
flanking labels
we can detect tandem duplications by
seeing a pattern present
twice next to each other either direct
or inverted starting at 30kb
on the top right there you see a
translocation which we detect when the
lenovo map in blue aligns for half with
one chromosome
and half with another chromosome or a
different part of the same chromosome
and then last bottom right an inversion
is detected
when a pattern is simply flipped around
in place
starting at 30 kb
our software will show you all the
structural variants that we detect in a
figure like this which is called a
circus plot
you see translocations in the middle
magenta and then the concentric circle
show you copy numbers
deletions inversions duplications etc
now if you click on any of these
structural variants we will show
you zoomed in map that shows you exactly
the alignment
of that structural variant with a
reference and you can even show the
molecules that were used
to call that structural variant
now if you don't want to use with our
software you can simply export these
structural variants as a vcf file
after filtering and use any software of
your choice
now what makes bioneno unique compared
to long-range sequencing technology is
really the enormous amount of data that
we can
collect in a short amount of time our
chips have three flow cells so you can
map three genomes at a time
and the instrument can collect the 100x
coverage which we recommend for
structural variation calling in genetic
disease
on nine human genomes per day per
instrument
or if you want to collect more data you
can run them longer
and collect as much as 400x coverage
which we recommend for cancer
and i'll tell you in a minute what we do
with that we can run the
instrument even longer and collect 1600x
coverage
of three human genomes in just three
days on average
an enormous amount of data and keep in
mind
that the cost per premium if you have an
instrument is just about 450 dollars for
that so
1600x 450 i think if you work with
long-range sequencing you immediately
understand that
uh there's an enormous gap there in what
we can deliver
compared to other methods so i want to
walk you through a few examples
of structural variants that were
detected with bionano that were missed
with other methods
short rate and long read sequencing and
i will start first with some genetic
disease research
cases what you're looking at here
is a part of chromosome 16 in a patient
with congenital diaphragmatic hernia
that's a severe genetic disorder a birth
defect that affects
the diaphragm in the lungs sometimes the
heart and very little is known really
about the
genetic basis of that so at mass general
hospital
it came used by nano to look at this
case where a microarray
had detected a two megabase duplication
now if you look on top of that figure
you see a copy number profile and our
copy number profile shows actually two
duplication events
and then when we look at our maps the
patient map is in blue
the reference is in green here you can
see that we can
show you the exact structure of this
event there's actually two duplications
the first one is direct
the other one is inverted and falls in
between
the first two duplications
we highlighted the genes that are
affected by these events and those are
all the candidate genes for this disease
they could not make sense of this region
with sequencing
mark ebbert from the mayo clinic used
our technology to look at the c9 or
f72 gene which can cause alzheimer's
disease if there's an expansion
of a gg ggcc repeat
that hexonucleotide repeat is of course
all
gc 100 gc and so these expansions of
that repeat are impossible to sequence
through
mark tried to do this with nanopore
sequencing and of course short-range
sequencing as well and failed
here you see that in a single brain
biopsy of a patient who died of als
we can see these different alleles these
different expansions of that repeat
from wild type all the way to 32 kb
and and there's of course an enormous
amount of power in being able to detect
that mosaicism
in the brain
here's another one that you cannot
sequence with short or wrong weed
sequencing
it's a disease called fshd fascious
capillary humeral muscular dystrophy
it's a genetic disorder that affects the
muscles of the face
the upper arms and the back and
it has a very odd genetic mechanism it
is caused by repeat contraction
a contraction of a repeat subtle
american chromosome 4
which is labeled here in this figure as
d4 z4
you see a wild type on top and you see a
diseased
allele at the bottom where you see
contraction of that repeat
this repeat is in a healthy person up to
300 kb
in length bio nano can span that repeats
with single molecules that is really our
strength our mega base size molecules
and so we can size that perfectly in
single molecules and we can also
distinguish between the pathogenic and
the non-pathogenic allele
which is labeled for qa and for qb here
segmental duplications or low copy
repeat
lcrs that they're labeled in this figure
are
very very large blocks of the genome
that are repeated multiple times
they're typically 50 to hundreds of kbs
in length and they can have they can be
blocked together in blocks as large as
in megabasers
by nano can't spend these segmented
applications with single molecules and
so
a team at emory university used our
technology to look at inversions
flanked by segmental duplications
in the 3q29 deletion syndrome
a large one-and-a-half megabase section
that is laid up in this figure as
canonical deletion is deleted and causes
the disease
but this team want to find out uh if
uh inversions in the parents in that
region can predispose to this disease
they try to do this with just about
every molecular method that exists but
only with bionano they were able to
detect these inversions because we have
molecules that span the 350 kb inversion
and both segmental duplications that
flank it
on skill molecules
mark everett again at the mayo clinic
has talked in
several papers about camouflage genes
these are genes that have
often repeating exons that make them
impossible to be analyzed by ngs
at the bottom there in orange you see
the read depth
from whole genome sequencing or exome
sequencing
for this gene and you see that it drops
to zero
for the binding domains of this gene
again because there are variably
repeated bonding domains in that gene
this gene is very important for
alzheimer's disease and
with bio nano on top there we were able
to call a deletion
in this gene in a patient who died of
alzheimer's disease
even though the repeats there make it
impossible to access them with
sequencing
now in cancer whether you're using him
studying heat malignancies or solid
tumors
we really have a great advantage over
these other technologies and that is
i mentioned before that we can collect
as much as 1600x coverage per sample
for the same price with that
we can dig very deep inside a complex
heterogeneous tumor
and detect structural variants that are
present at just one percent allele
fraction
no other technology can do this in an
unbiased genome
wide manner
and so two examples from cancer samples
here
is a uvl melanoma sample that is
characterized by
typically a loss of expression of gene
one
this is a result from the curie
institute in france
in this particular sample they found no
genomic explanation
for this lack of expression but bioneno
was able to detect a deletion of 740
base pairs right
in the promoter region of this gene now
we plotted the gc content
there underneath and you see that right
at the site of that deletion
the gc content goes up to about 80
percent and that made it invisible
to the methods of full genome sequence
that they used
here's another example from the cordelia
institute
where they studied hepatocellular
carcinomas
on the left there you see the circus
plot of a tumor that showed no
replication stress you see a few
translocations in a very stable copy
number profile
and on the right you see a sample that
looks identical
under the microscope but had an enormous
amount of replication stress
you see a massive number of
translocations and also a highly
abnormal copy number profile now the
difference between these two was the
insertion of the hepatitis by
hepatitis b virus just upstream of the
cyclin e1 gene which you see in the map
on top there
we call this insertion and so the
promoter of the hepatitis virus will
turn
on that cyclin gene the cell cycle will
continue
out of control before the dna
replication has happened and that causes
that signature
this is an important measure this
signature of replication stress because
it may qualify this patient for the use
of
arp inhibitors
and then last i want to touch for just a
second on
cytogenomics because in cytogenetics
right now
we use decades or or even half a century
old technology stereotype fish
chromosomal microarray
and a recent study that was just
published from red about university in
nemagen
used by nana to look at 48 leukemia
genomes
and found that bionnano can call
all the variants so 100 concordance with
the standard of care that means all the
variants picked up by karyotype
and by fish and by array in all 48
samples
combined many sequencing-based methods
have tried and failed to replace
traditional cytogenetics but by nano can
and the advantage here is that you can
replace a very
confusing to be honest workflow that you
see on the left
where depending on the tissue type you
end up with cell culture or not cell
separation or not
different methods of dna extraction and
of labeling and of amplification and
harvesting and hybridization to come up
with a number of different results that
that need to be integrated
all of this can be replaced with a
single workflow where you have a
universal dna extraction
independent of the sample type has been
discussed with rsp kits
and then one instrument generates the
data that gets analyzed
all together so i want to end here
by summarizing that we call uh
structural variants starting at 500 base
pairs genome-wide with extremely high
sensitivities up to 99
and ppvs starting at 97
so almost no false positives
and then in cancer we can collect 1600x
coverage
per sample that brings us down to 1
allele fraction
all this just starting at 450 dollars if
you own an instrument
but that's not the only way to get by
nanodata you can of course get the
sapphire system
shown on the right there you can also
take part in a reagent rental model
where with the commitment of just 120
genomes at 550
we will get you a sapphire instrument to
use or we also have an in-house
service where you simply send us your
samples and we will get you the data
back
and we are up and running even right now
during these times
so with that i want to thank you for
your time
and address some of the questions
that we've received and i will start
to ask ben a question about
size selection is there any size
selection mechanism of the disk
uh at all then
thanks everybody thanks ben is there any
size selection of the disc uh no the um
the the disc is introduced once the the
input material has been lysed
and then megabases of dna diffuse in
into the solution the disk simply
captures what's there
so it's not meaningfully uh performing
any size selection
another question then will the magnet
affect the dna
in any way
[Music]
uh so the the dna binds to the magnetic
disk um it's it's not a pull in opposite
directions like you can see with
bead based approaches it's just a
one magnetic disc with a microstructure
that enables the dna to bind to it out
of solution
so it's it's not exhibiting the
mechanical force of
of other approaches
i'll stay on the disc here the magnetic
disc that allows binding of dna
resembles circulomics nanobind disk
is that the same composition or what's
the difference in the protocols
uh that's right so it's uh it is the
same composition but they
are different protocols so um
we have partnered with circulomics and
developed
workflows specific to our
our needs of of dna purity
and develop the workflows and specific
chemistry
around the bio nanoprep sp dna isolation
great we have a few questions about
yield the extraction with 650
microliters of blood
and will yield a very low final yield
it may be long reads but not enough dna
for multiple reads what is the typical
yield
of 650 microliters of blood
that's right so uh just i'll take that
one step by step so 650 microliters of
blood
um a a small sampling of that
is uh is used to determine a white blood
cell count
and then from there the volume
equivalent of
a 1.5 million white blood cells is
carried forward
so that's really a commonality between
cell blood bone marrow aspirate
we use 650 microliters because that's
a pretty conservative high volume of
blood
um whole human blood from uh healthy
normal patients
anywhere from 250 microliters to maybe
up to 500 microliters uh we'll get you
that 1.5 million
now if um if there's any
any factor where the white blood cell
count would be abnormally low
you could simply uh potentially titrate
a different volume
just so long as you can isolate uh 1.5
million
white blood cells and then
once you started at that common point
you you proceed through the isolation
and then the target output
is anywhere from 35 to 150
nanograms per microliter in
concentration
great somewhat related question a
scientist here
stores frozen blood samples in 1ml
volumes
can we scale up from the recommended 650
microliters
um potentially sure so in that case
if if you wanted to follow the workflow
to a t
you would simply take that 1ml subsample
and and from it see what volume
equivalent get to 1.5 million
white blood cells and then you
you simply have uh an excess of of blood
that you could
use toward whatever other purpose
yeah how do you quantitate this kind of
dna what method is used
great question so uh quantitation
uh we just need some fluorometric
approach uh
so in in the field typically we'll use
the qubit fluorimetry um that
pico green works as well
an approach like nano drop isn't going
to be precise enough unfortunately
yeah okay we have another question here
uh is there any difference between
high molecular weight dna and what we
are calling ultra high molecular weight
dna
for human blood samples do the
separation techniques differ between
these
above mentioned to molecular weight dna
uh no um no so
uh there there's not meant to be a
difference in in terminology there
dna is um
we want it as high molecular weight as
as we can get it
i think what i can add here maybe
been is that many dna isolation kits
claim
that they isolate high molecular weight
dna and you get molecules that are maybe
30 to 50 kb in length and i think the
difference is that
at binano we require or want megabase
size molecules
that's where that distinction falls i
believe
does the dna isolation protocol work for
single stranded
dna
uh nope so the uh the output is
uh around a target of nine micrograms uh
double-stranded dna
yeah similar questions for viruses
does the protocol work for dna isolation
from viruses
uh so so viral genomes are going to be
a much smaller uh than the the target
molecule length
uh for bionano prep so we haven't uh
explored whether it could work in
principle
um but you know much of the benefit
would likely be lost
okay we have quite a few questions here
so i will just keep going
if that's okay with you then the growing
of plant tissues isn't affecting dna
fragment length at all
methods like chopping the tissue may be
better
is the grinding affecting fragment links
yeah let me uh let me put up my plant
slide again that that's a very good
question
so i mentioned a few uh separate
workflows that we have
for plant tissue um if if it's processed
fresh
and kept that way um each of the three
shown here the base
the high polyphenol and the high
polysaccharide
those use chopping to homogenize the
plant tissue
and then that's processed through a
plant homogenization buffer which
releases the nuclei
that is certainly one option uh liquid
nitrogen grinding
is a separate one i'd recommend it if
the plant tissue were stored
uh frozen if it's already been frozen
um you may as well keep it that way in
liquid nitrogen
for the duration of homogenizing it in
which case it's easiest to grind
we we see that it's more important
really to keep
a lot of liquid nitrogen around and to
keep refilling
and and keep that tissue
cold during the grinding process
if it's spiking in temperature as you're
grinding it that
that will have an impact um but
if if the liquid nitrogen if there's
plenty of it and you're able to grind it
away
it's it's sometimes necessary if the
plant tissue is
is particularly tough um
or you know or otherwise but really
there
there is an option if there's a concern
about treating the tissue too rough
you could certainly elect to chop it um
but in the realities of plant tissue is
it's it's tough to use sometimes
uh and and the grinding can be a benefit
just to get through it
great another question here what is the
maximum time
after tissue snap freezing for
high quality genomic dna to be able to
be recovered
that's a good question um we
uh to my knowledge haven't looked at
this uh
systematically um i think the
the ultimately important uh thing is
that it be snap frozen and then
kept at minus 80 without freeze thaw
cycles
uh really at that point i i would
imagine it comes down to
particularity as of of that sample and
end of your freezer maintaining that
temperature
uh somewhat related how should i keep
high molecular weight genomic dna after
extraction
from a cell in four degrees or at room
temperature
how long can i keep it in ideal
conditions
sure so great great points both
great options both to keep it at room
temperature or 4c
the important thing is you don't want to
freeze it once once the dna is
solubilized
um and just uh as a workflow convenience
um typically our uh
our users are turning that sample over
into label dna and then running it out
on a chip
pretty promptly if you do want to store
it
room temperature is is fine
maybe out for a couple weeks anything
longer term than that
you can put it at 4c but it's it's
pretty user electable in practice
great we have a few more questions about
the sv calling
that i can take what's the repeat
expansion detection sensitivity
now it's an interesting question because
we can automatically call structural
variants starting at 500 base pairs
we cannot see very very small expansions
or contractions of repeat so if you just
have
a few copies of a trinucleotide repeat
we cannot detect that
so the type of repeat expansion
genes that we can detect are the ones
that are larger and that typically fail
with pcr so there's some good
complementarity there
that is uh fragile x myotonic dystrophy
als and a number of other ones so if the
difference between the wild type allele
and the expanded allele
is more than several hundred base pairs
we will be able
to detect that another question here
it says the starting size of its feed
detection is 50 kb
but what is the range of sv sizes so a
little correction there
we call structural variants starting at
500 base pairs
it's on the screen right now actually
for deletions and insertions
for some of the other structural
variants where we need to be able to
detect a pattern like in a translocation
that needs to align with the genome it's
a 50 kb minimum
the range of this fees that we can
detect goes all the way from 500 base
pairs to entire chromosomes
we detect unemployed ease so chromosome
arm deletions or duplications
entire chromosomes and any anything uh
shorter than that can be depicted with a
copy number tool
and also with our maps
again as you can see here another
question here can this method detect
mosaics
yes absolutely we talked about the one
percent allele fraction
so we can detect uh mosaic samples
absolutely
surely uh depending on the amount of
coverage that you can get we can go as
low as one percent um and uh
and and so yes we have plenty of
examples of
mosaic cases for fshd for a number of
other
genetic diseases
we don't have a lot of time left we'll
maybe
answer two more questions i am aware of
advantages of these long-range
sequencing platforms but it comes with
major limitations of high error rates
around fifty percent in case of
like iron nanopore how accurate is
optical mapping reads as compared to
center or illumina
what is the error rate you have observed
in general it's a bit of a complicated
question
of course because we're comparing
sequencing methods where you read
the a c g's and t's with a method like
ours that just calls the structural
variance
by looking at these changes in label
patterns
so yes for nanopore sequencing the error
rate this is about the range that you
called for pac bio it's actually a lot
lower i think the main difference
between our technology
and sequencing based methods is that we
are the only technology that can call
these structural variants
genome-wide unbiased with this very high
sensitivity so
it's not a fair comparison because we
don't give you single base pairs
we can't show you these smallest
variants but when it comes to structural
variants there's just no comparison in
our performance
versus the long-range sequencing
platforms and there's actually quite a
few
neutral studies like from the human
genome and sp consortium
that proved that
i think that is all the time we have
any questions that we were not able to
address
during the live periods will be
addressed
by ben clifford or me via the contact
information that you provided when you
registered so with that i'd like to
thank
ben clifford for his time today and all
of you for joining
uh we want to thank lapra roots for
organizing today's
educational webcast as well on the top
left in the resources tab
you have access to our sapphire platform
brochure nrsv white paper
and please contact us at info binance
genomics.com
with any questions that you may have
this webcast can be viewed on demand
uh lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
and we encourage you that you share this
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event there's a survey that will
pop up on your screen right now we
appreciate your participation
and with that thank you and until next
time bye